this year marks 70 years of queen
elizabeth ii's rule
she is britain's longest reigning
monarch in history outraining closest
competition queen victoria by nearly
seven years
[Applause]
and what better way to celebrate her
majesty's platinum jubilee than with a
special pud
and i think what we're looking for is
something that tastes just right
buckingham palace has revealed its
programme of performances and
celebrations fit for a queen so here is
everything that you need to know about
what's happening and when
from the queen of the country to the
queen of baking dame mary berry will be
part of a judging panel tasked with
finding a platinum pudding the contest
is open to the public and will select a
dish worthy of making the queen's
special year think of something that you
might eat at an afternoon tea or indeed
after your main meal as a as a dessert
or a pudding so think pies crumbles
cakes it could be any of those sorts of
things but we are thinking sweet rather
than savory seems only fair with queen
victoria's namesake cake the victorious
sponge still being enjoyed by us brits
today alongside the special pudding
trees are being planted which will be
presented to the queen at the end of the
year as a special reminder of the
celebrations
between the 12th and the 15th of may
more than 1 000 performers and 500
horses will take part in a show at
winter castle crowds will be taken on a
journey through history from elizabeth
the first to the present day
on the 2nd of june a special trooping
the colour will kick off a four day bank
holiday weekend on horse guards parade
in central london
on the same day beacons will be lit in
certain places around the uk and the
world at the same time as buckingham
palace the next day saint paul's
cathedral will hold a service of
thanksgiving
and on saturday the 4th of june the
palace will hold a celeb-packed party
tickets for which will be available for
uk residents to apply for for the rest
of us on sunday the 5th of june there's
the big jubilee lunch where everyone is
encouraged to come together and break
some bread to mark the final day of the
long weekend
a pageant will parade through the mao on
this day too with dancers musicians
military personnel and key workers
telling the story of the queen's 70 year
reign
school children have been asked to get
involved by creating a picture of how
they would like the planet to look in 70
years time with the best ones printed on
flags for a river of hope which will be
used in the pageant
and in july a trio of exhibitions will
take place at the royal residences in
windsor buckingham palace and hollyrood
house these will show off some of queen
elizabeth's dresses worn at previous
jubilees as well as items from her
private jewellery collection
it will no doubt be an historic year for
the queen but after a rocky road for the
family in the last few years it will no
doubt spark conversation of the role of
the royal family in the years to come
[Music]